you
okay here we go this is fifty-five
minutes of crazy house chest this is the
stefanova arena time controls - - there
will be no time burners alright let's
take that guy out and develop strike at
f7 indirectly
all right let's recapture mm-hmm
thought you might do that let's point at
a square over here make something good
happen maybe on this square or is there
not gonna go this pond that they placed
here maybe I'll use over for safety for
my king I'm still learning a lot with
this variant now one approach is just to
be really defensive put some pieces
right around your king they're good at
defending squares and rules out any
possibilities for your opponent to drop
pieces near your King so probably just
take that huh and I feel like
I already want to put in a pond like
right here hmm
let's hmm is this a moment already just
strike somehow with a pond
I don't think so hmm let's throw up on
in there take my bishop I don't want to
take with the Queen she's just too
vulnerable
further up the board she goes okay now
I'm really thinking about a pond drop
right here but not so fast let's get
another piece involved castle I don't
know if I want a castle just yet I do a
pond drop I might want to put it here as
a defensive hmm yeah it'll take if I put
upon here maybe it's time for a night
drop let's go here think offensively for
a little bit f7o
that move um let's get that in there II
got an
- Bishop upon I want to castle
I want to I want to line up some
defensive pieces here have a defensive
approach yeah let me change
let's put upon here strong a strong
defender tuck the King in right there
yeah I like this grouping of pawns nice
shelter for the King Castle where can I
put in a night drop maybe talking this
week one this week bond here identifying
these unprotected pieces all right let's
Castle I like the security I have for my
King these 3 squares weld this here
there's a night drop here hmm nobody
better move buddy let's start with
Bishop here hmm doing that you got to
move you got to move Knight here now or
even bishop no you got to move
oh that's gonna that's going to be
painful
I missed that move Bishop on g4 all
right it's gonna get wild here coming in
for the kill
here we go Bishop h6 bring in the heat
oh okay didn't see that one coming
repetition you'll be the first draw ever
crazy house there you go mm-hmm draw by
repetition to position all right
Saxon pieces now bring the pain um I
want a pawn I want to put upon here
let's trade pawns
all right pawn drop on g7 I insist I
insist
I want to get a rook here actually I'm
going to get the rook it's trapped how
do you like that
give me the rook Knight here I'm at f6
I'm going to drop my rook though I got
their queen let's take here with check
where's the mate where's the mate there
it is back determine oh I see how long
that game took seven minutes that's why
these are lengthier time controls take
forever I don't want to play without the
increment because you know it's too hard
drop those pieces fast enough all right
are you going to sac on f7 or or not
let's guard g5 there go ahead go for it
and go with that
it's Castle okay
how to take I know with this transfer
this night over here okay hmm
are you already lining something up here
it's kind of offset this pressure
against these two squares I don't know
if this is so right I might need to put
my Bishop here hmm maybe a bishop here
throw a punch and defend or Knight here
hmm Queen here I end up in Knight takes
pawn and I don't know should I already
be thinking offensively let's try that
that'll show them go ahead hit me with
the fork that's what I thought thought
you might do that
alright let's see if you give me your
knight okay Knight takes pawn and then
Knight drop on h4 yeah okay Wow feels
like this is already trouble I need some
defense here they got two bishops they
could drop yet yikes I got four this is
the four Knights variation oh yeah
well maybe I could just sack the Queen
here on takes yeah why not cares about
the Queen actually that wasn't what I
wanted to do I took what the wrong piece
oh man
alright maybe we'll try that abort try
something different
Wow look at the c7 look at his e6 Square
crazy finally I'm out of a pin I have to
worry about four crazy minor pieces
that's now no no no now's the time to
think offensively right not quite
let's do that defense soon though
there's going to be an accident
happening here pawn on f3 bring the pain
maybe the bishop is better here so I
could put the pawn on the beastly
second-ranked
I'm sure that's how you were all viewing
it put the pawns on those squares
monsters it's got to be right feels too
good oh yeah look at that intersection
square that's where it's at oh there is
that move isn't there all right let's
see what happen
pawn right here right now take the
initiative Queen drop right here with
check maybe hmm that's not working out I
got these squares covered still on the
rook threatening mate okay where's the
mate starts with that oh yeah now we're
cooking now we are definitely cooking
take that rook with's check where's the
mate
he's running let's do that move don't
know if that was best
let's throw a check here check there
we're close to mate another check make a
block am I going to get made it they
have a moment do something they leave a
queen though I'm going to drop a knight
for me less than 10 yeah they ran out of
fuel fast huh King had a run for the
hills I have these two squares covered
tricky Knight drop back to tournament
four is where we are at 42 minutes
plenty of time not on the front page but
I'm off to a good start I don't think
I've had one of my first two games
before playing in at crazy house
tournament while recording at least man
that was pretty wild in that game that
six square they were really hammering
away at e6 I was in that pin all right
offset the the squares that they're
controlling with their last move let's
go here will they sack and do this I
don't know that many players do that
okay let's take take again expose their
Queen and should I already drop let's do
that Queen back on them I believe is
best you know what I will definitely
take that Queen alright game's far from
over but I'm like in my position let's
start with the knight right here
these Knights striking right at the
heart go right right at the right for
the heart
Kano style for crazy-house we're taking
that rip the heart right out give a
check and throw a queen right in there
and that'll be it see see what happens
when you you strike at the heart oh yeah
that was not a good idea to sack the
Queen like that but maybe they just
missed a that their queen was even
hanging I don't know they were going for
a quick strike at f2 our f7 scholars
mate style already yeah I basically
always go like this is black I don't
know if it's good but I know I'm working
out so far
I'll break the pin you know whenever
your pawns are off of your own seventh
rank now you have to watch out for crazy
white pawns that might end up here like
I'm already thinking about rook here but
let's do this first I don't think upon
here is going to be that much of a
bother but at some point dropping in
here with tempo against a rook usually a
good idea to take measures against that
that's a pretty annoying move I should
have stopped that alright we're going to
take and then play here to try and stop
a pawn drop on this square they're ready
to drop upon here and that would have
really hurt me and now they're giving
that pawn up you just drop upon it's
really like dropping two pawns because I
take it and then I could put it back on
my side I think I have time to do that
I'm going to do it and then build up
shelter what a nice shelter in for my
King you could really have a lopsided
material advantage and crazy house like
one side having eight minor pieces for
rooks to Queens and your opponent having
like nothing ouch
there is that move isn't there oh well
hang on hang on for a second yeah
do that don't hurt me too bad all righty
I'm in a pinch still Wow all righty
let's see what you got about even on
time I have yet to do anything against
their king but I got these guys it's
nice to have a mix of different pieces
on Knight Bishop rook on it has the same
one of each all right well I think I
already
drop this rook right here opposite their
king it defends squares that they just
put pressure on it also stops a drop
here for when it's taken opposite their
King though maybe I could do this and
just look for regular make by regular
means okay we're going to put this guy
up right here there you go
keep your king nice and tucked in look
at this look at this little home right
here you can't get at the king this is a
beastly home this is how it this is how
you dream of your crazy house King
position it's looking just like this
look at this pigs on g2 pawn on g2 stops
all that nonsense huh I should have went
with this instead looking for that mate
all right all right all right all right
um
all right I should really start thinking
offensively now I think now is the time
and you start dropping some pieces
Bishop h3 all right let's see how they
take the Queen's gonna be trapped if she
takes yeah she's a cooked piece now
unless there's some crazy drop yeah I
like how I have all these squares
covered really well Knight drop in here
they'd have to investor a lot down a
time yeah that's what they're trying
should I take
or just run away hmm I go here there's a
fork um okay
there huh take here so I get your queen
yes just what I wanted all right
crazytown check where the checks I
should be able to mate no no right here
I should have that this is mate no my
name is calculated I think I did know I
saw the Queen are you talking about I
got it here and then there who will take
it back to tournament sixteen twelve
twelve okay um what game number is this
no I think this is only my second time
playing his white I like have on the
bishop here not saying I will take on f7
but I like having this that's a free
pawn I'll definitely take that all right
you block I take another pawn all right
I already feel like I should have
something against their king definitely
hmm pond drop right here I could take
this pawn let's do that I have to reap I
just just have three extra pawns now
threatening here coordinating your
pieces on specific squares is a big deal
it's good a good strategy hmm there is
that move however I
could simply go here and defend are they
going to do a pawn block here it's not
working like a pawn push here I could
drop a pawn in to f7 fort I could do
pawn drop here to win my knight but yeah
I don't know about that okay now there
should be something here just take that
night yeah and now I'm going to drop a
pawn on f3 I think although no should I
already be thinking offensively a knight
right here now I'm going to be a bit
more cautious let's just offset the
presence this Bishop has in my in my
position the squares that it's trying to
control he kind of puts a halt to that
maybe I'll put my other two pawns right
here okay thought you might do that but
as mentioned before I have that move
it's got to be painful actually let me
go into my preferences real quick game
behavior promote to Queen never not on
crazy house I'm thinking about a knight
here let's get it alright I could also
go with a pawn right here again or a
knight I think I like that idea I'm
pretty sure I could take up the
initiative right now so let's make it
work I have another night even and how
do you like that a fork and a half so
I'm getting the Queen
I want to take her right away something
better don't think so I should take her
right now mmm clean here go after the
rook I don't know about that
maybe threatening to drop a knight and
then drop a queen into c7 okay take this
bishop oh there's a knight drop here
should I just do a queen drop right here
now queen dropping the rook isn't
hanging now where's my time let's just
um oh I don't know let's let's castle
going to take my knight okay you're
doing that let's go here I just want
some exchanges I want to go after their
King now
all right okay there's got to be
something good here okay he's got to go
okay I have the initiative and I should
keep it right here here no matter what
and we should be having mate somehow
where's the mate right here and then a
pond back on this square for a second
time and that's mate this time around
okay 2016 16 16 five four five all right
I'll take it less than 30 minutes in
this one top guy hope chess master
morning coffee and handy five stars I
guess pehoe vaq okay not a good idea to
get into a time race with this guy
speedy will he sack on f7 we're going to
find out no
all right Oh take back oh I can't do a
take back oh man that's gonna come back
to hurt me all right that's going to
hurt me Bishop g4 man all right well
it's not over
get back there that's where you were
supposed to go buddy that's where you're
supposed to go I'm fighting down to
pieces basically right now because of
that not just one two you could do it
though this will be the most amazing
comeback ever oh I got a pond that pond
is going to be this this guy's going to
act as compensation for being down
basically two minor pieces Wayne do you
see aha defense work around those guys
let's just see let's just see you try to
do that oh boy
let's go here and drop a pond here like
yesterday as soon as possible
mend these gaps in your position before
it's too late a quad structure you're
going to do some drop here now I have it
covered with this guy let's see how you
feel with a knight right here striking
at the heart g2 looking at a poun drop
one day right here hmm watch this tactic
you ready take that guy Knight check
here grab the bishop with check drop a
bishop into e2 that's the that's the big
plan all this just to land a silly Fork
is it worth it who knows we're going to
give it a shot though maybe I take here
instead
it's not really that big of a deal being
down a piece when it comes to crazy
house well in a way but there's
certainly opportunities to kind of fight
back all righty
do I even want to take the rook
important question maybe I take this guy
instead that rooks going nowhere
how about Knight here yeah let's let's
see if we could grab another piece over
here there they're kind of scary
you might sack Bishop takes pawn rook
takes lure my king out and do a pawn
drop here yeah we'll see I'd like to
take here and after their Queen
recaptures I take here okay
now their queen is definitely vulnerable
let's throw a punch at her and take here
next yeah this is starting to feel
pretty good now I have the initiative
against their King and should I take
care how should we do it
Knight takes pawn yeah rip the heart
right out of that structure right there
there you go I'll take here twice oh
yeah yeah let's go here I should
night job and I didn't do well to get
the initiative although I should
certainly have something here you
kidding me starting with a tricky night
there we go
he wears where the defenses where are
the defenses where should that pawn be
dropped let's go here controls two
squares instead of one careful and he
has three six minor pieces but they're
not on the board yet this is where my
queen now brings the pain bring the pain
and if their tactics don't work out with
dropping minor pieces around here and
there might be actually night check here
Knight checked there it doesn't work out
I'm definitely going to have something
it's their king okay they're going in to
prevent here prevent mode drop a rook
now or grab this pawn I'm ready to drop
a pawn on g2 now oh yeah hitting the
rook as well they're down on time here
we go now we're cooking Knight here mate
actually it's going to be mate Bishop
takes pawn Queen takes and there is that
move or even rook h1 drop in the corner
for me yikes
that wasn't cool to start out like that
but I fought back somehow that Mel
slipped
23 minutes left and this one so far so
good
can I go perfect we're gonna see all
right third time playing this guy I
don't know if they're crazy house games
or regular games okay
let's just go here I've been having
success with not being aggressive with
the bishop but more defensive here
preventing potential pins against my
knight
okay let's take and I think if I'm not
careful a pawn gets dropped here because
of this coordination between the bishop
and night so that said should I be
dropping upon right here now we're going
to take and then do a pawn drop right
here if Queen here I don't have Knight
takes like I did in that one game but
I'd have a bishop block should I already
play Knight h4m no let's get some more
development and I want to keep this
night in my pocket oh there's that move
all right let's go here yep / - g8
forfeiting like
counseling rights but you know if I take
I'm just inviting a piece to develop and
control this square I want to take back
control of g7 and he could be an
attacking piece too huh
oh boy I'm in trouble yeah my Kings
getting lured right out here oh boy
prepare to run King you're gonna be
doing a lot of it where are you
hang tight now hang tight don't don't
lose hope here just back up
it's gonna be all right little scary for
sure but yeah they could do a pawn drop
right here defense defense
okay you're all right you're doing all
right here buddy
look here pawn takes King takes pawn
drop follow maybe I just take the pawn
and then take here I'll have two pawns
for the rook yeah that's compensation
that's compensation you can't drop a
rook with any great effect
meanwhile I'll build up my King safety
there you go look at the positives
they're thinking about something else
clearly Knight here I'll just take oh
they might be thinking of that because
of Bishop check as a fall out move
looking for these uh-oh very nice that
move as well huh but I could take here
no Knight -
pawn takes now I'm going to grab that
night yeah let's see what you got man I
have two nights in a bishop if they're
not quick I am going to build up okay
hmm
I should probably
bully drop upon right here control the
squares that they try to control I think
I should have this I'm going to put
pieces here every move every move unless
they take and I have to take back okay
time to build up fast or on there
Bishop here I don't care don't care
about that Bishop I'm going to drop a
pond that's so fast flying very
defensively I realize maybe I have
enough defense GG pond defense double
isolated G ponds put a knight on h4 how
about that Bishop here this was not a
good idea
um six seconds oh we can't allow that to
happen
night on h6 God defend that square are
we doing defend Bishop okay we're
building up we're building up here we
got a tricky night I'm out of fuel look
at this wall look at this wall that
wasn't a good idea
okay give me some pieces
give me some pieces I like my king
shelter yeah how are you going to get at
my king how are you going to get at my
king I'm slowly getting there hmm
what a crazy game craziness give me a
bishop there you go oh no um just defend
wow this is nutty oh boy
defend that I'm banking a ton of time
they just they just lost some material
there that's pretty serious
I just dropped like two pieces there oh
there's that move hmm all I've been
doing is just reacting to their play
I guess here and do a night drop okay
they could do a rook drop here mmm
my King has officially stripped of his
defenses all right you're going to run
over here King this is where there's a
pawn this is where there's pawn shelter
Oh
ooh all right that's all right keep
going keep going you got this oh okay
they're taking that rook but now is my
time to strike it's not too late
it really isn't hmm maybe it is could do
pawn drops I wanna do a knight drop on
e2 there you go keep working man keep
work and make it happen
mmm give me the initiative somehow oh
boy Fischer
spawn it's a check um I don't think I
have time to take that I don't know
yikes
mm-hmm oh boy trouble I'm getting mated
yep what's happening soon there it is
oh what a game what again
Jerri you're too defensive of that one
you gotta be thinking more offensively
oh I know I know I know
it's too little too late man I had such
a I had such a wall or what I thought
was a wall and then they exploited that
a ecig square ah I just needed just a
little more time that was the approach I
was gunning for where I just react to
their deeper their offensive stuff early
on and then uh you know come back later
and bring the pain ah didn't quite work
man I really enjoyed that game though
that was a good one
all right get back on the horse h3 and
they're ready let's get this guy working
there are they going to allow Bishop to
g5 hmm I may have had something in that
game too once I was throwing some uh
once I started throwing some punches all
right let's make something happen
against this pin night maybe huh okay
don't know that I want to actually take
their queen comes out and then they
could think about taking here with check
maybe I should have taken here first
I should have captured then here and
then here stuff this doesn't feel right
because I could take and then drop a
bishop here although I don't know if
that's the best piece to drop in there
let's take here for starters now we're
going to drop a knight there strike at
the pinned piece strike at g7 only 11
minutes left and this one that game took
forever
Wow is that a 10-plus minute game man
less than 50 for my opponent all right
this has to be good I'll take with this
guy I want to have a the knight still
controlling these two squares keep my
knight on board well also a way to view
it is that they don't have a knight that
they could drop now I gave up my bishop
but I have a knight that could do some
damage how how are you going to make
that happen
knight on f5 no if I don't want to take
him back I guess we will but I'm
thinking about a knight drop here within
a bishop drop on one of these two or
really ideally I'd like to have a knight
here and a pawn drop on this square
let's get him back here
strong squares even in regular chess
right these holes these gaps in the
position that can't be right
fish up here pretty deadly now yeah
that's pretty strong threat I did
consider this for a moment
Knight takes here it's close to mate
yeah making to threat actually if the
Queen moves its Knight takes pawn and
then a pawn drop here for mate ouch
that's gonna do it just enough gas I'll
take it
nine minutes left 40 36 36 22 all right
let's see if we could win all but one
first time playing against this guy I
don't believe the Sicilian is good in
crazy house because of this square a
pawn drop here like if I have a pawn
connected with the knight here it's game
over here here and then take the night
and night drop on c7
I'm already threatened some pretty
devastating things take the night like
this right here this shouldn't be
survive you can't survive this I don't
think that's a check to take here let's
take that one okay I got a knight got a
rook how vulnerable is their king I
could go here and then take here with
check but they'll drop a bishop and
throw a punch back at my queen so I
don't
how bad of a shelter this is for their
king maybe a safer than my own hmm they
have two tricky nights right here it's
frightening to trap their queen with
rook there or even drop a rock right
here for check right next to the king
boom
who saw that Queen trap coming the old
queen trap okay okay okay do I even need
to take the bishop where are there
Knight drops with check no we're right
here but I'll just take threatening mate
with the Queen on see he and I have time
to take my queen that's it I think
they're in trouble maybe a knight drop
here hitting the rook defending Queen c8
maybe I also have night check and then
dropping a queen here as an idea let's
see what defense they come up with here
queen c8 is the mate threat queen drop
on c8 mate they defended however as
mentioned I could play Knight here but
now I can't do queen drop here the
knight controls that square as well
queen drop here King here I'm not going
to do that just yet I'm going to scoop
up this Bishop threatening mate next now
no they'll take my rook now wait I have
a queen drop right here
yeah let's flush the King towards the
center of the board and now take the
bishop yeah Queen here bishop drop here
you can't survive this I don't think
there's too much now yeah just throw him
in there
that's mate forty thirty six thirty six
twenty four five minutes left this might
be the last game maybe alright yeah I
don't know these see pond openings I
don't know about that like these uh
standard moves all right this is leaving
already a hole on this square so I'm
going to look to control this square
with the pawn and one day drop a piece
in there let's not be so quick to move
him actually moving him early might
leave some opportunity like it might
open up a possibility of a white
dropping upon here you know he's
unprotected as soon as the bishop moves
and could soon turned into a target
for white that said I still need to
develop him huh and they don't have
anything to drop I think this is fine I
like having a you know being in a
position with one of your pieces where
you could take your opponent's piece but
they can't take your piece you know in
case you need the night at some point
you could always take them and then drop
them next turn
especially when it when it's with check
here so I'm not going to take him just
yet don't take big pieces let's just go
let's go - yeah they're in a pin
let's open things up don't know how I
would recapture okay they're going with
that I could take this pawn now I'm
going to maybe drop upon right in here
you know this is looking pretty good I
think so I could take this Knight and
drop a knight in here right here there's
a gap and then take this Knight and then
drop one here get the rook at least
it's close to well no not close to mate
but hmm what I really would like is a
pond take the rook a pond drop of rook
drop here getting the Queen don't know
that I want to take the rook actually
yeah I do because I get still some
initiative here where like I dropped the
rook and attack their Bishop control
some squares relatively close to their
king they could take my night with check
less than two minutes left in the
tournament so this is a almost certainly
going to be the last game all right they
did go in for that so now I have a
bishop that I could drop here are they
even going to take my knight in the
corner I could put my rook here and
threaten the rook drop getting the Queen
it's maybe not a bad idea
are they going to start any action
against my king now they're not even
going to take but now I could get their
Queen just like that and this should not
be survivable Queen drop right here
already no not so fast let's just go
here threatening Queen here and then a
new Queen on the board drop for me yeah
be good enough this is this is pretty
overwhelming maybe going straight in for
the queen drop here was good I'm just
going to do it I could take this night
and I should and then you know let's
drop a rook there let's see how they
defend I could always take a piece out
with check now and that'll actually be
mate the Owen I got it in before the
tournament ended with eight seconds
remaining
Oh just out of the podium 44 38 36 28
and yeah 100 111 took part in this from
The Roommate how many less than 50 at
the start I thought at least let's see
who else took part in this one the
stefanova tournament not quite squeaky
clean but better than before the other
tournaments I competed in and recorded
and uploaded ah that yeah that game I
lost I think was my favorite
I was intense walked my King all the way
over the Queen side and that one the one
where I was super defensive all right to
the 111 of you who took part in this
good games all alright
you